hey it's me eric stonestreet cam from  modern family and i'm here to hand out  some superlatives to my old co-workers  what's their names i don't remember  [Music]  me  [Music]  most likely to sneak in snacks a  thousand percent sofia vergara she has  marshmallows and hot tamales hidden all  over that set i'm sure the mice at 20th  century fox are still scrounging on them  right now  most likely to be like their character  in real life uh that's a toss up  julie i think a little bit yeah she's  pretty energetic on top of things  taskmaster lovely  [Music]  most likely to get a spin off those days  are gone no more modern family everyone  you've had enough  [Music]  most likely to nap on set would probably  be ed o'neill you know he's older  most likely to interrupt a digital media  thing with a knock on the door that  person  thanks for having me drew  this was fun i'm in the smallest room  i've ever been in  which is great  [Music]  you